first fires then floods
hopes are dwindling in this town that
missing loved ones will still be alive
those who survived the floods in
buzzkirt on the black sea wait anxiously
for news
with a population of fewer than nine
thousand most people will know someone
affected by this tragedy
for elias the devastation is difficult
to comprehend
my aunt is missing her husband is
missing her twin grandchildren are
missing the wife of our building manager
is missing along with their two children
his relative and local business owner
turon describes the moment flood waters
rushed in at the very moment they were
paying tribute to his uncle at his
funeral
people were shouting and screaming
asking others to run away we looked and
saw the flood waters coming our way from
the direction of the post office we fled
up hill running past the bridge to bring
ourselves to safety
the flood described as one of turkey's
worst was the second natural disaster to
strike the country this month
chaos in the north just as authorities
had declared wildfires in the south had
been brought under control
on friday president erdogan visited the
region declaring three disaster zones
he promised to defer taxes and offered
relief for all those affected
the nation's disaster agency has
deployed nearly six thousand personnel
to the hardest hit areas
almost half a meter of rain has fallen
in less than three days causing rivers
to overflow
torrents of water have been tossing cars
filling streets with debris and wiping
entire houses from their foundations
more than 2 000 people have been
evacuated from their homes many with the
help of helicopters and boats
some having fled to their rooftops as a
last resort
hundreds of villages are without
electricity and people say they can't
reach their loved ones by phone
volunteers are doing what they can to
deliver aid as rescue teams continue to
try to save more lives
in this town where buildings line the
waterfront and rivers can't expand
further this disaster experts say is
down to humans and climate
change and scientists warn the worst is
yet to come
jillian wolf al jazeera